va bene grazie a tutti l'avevo per
essere qui è stato bellissimo venire
nella vostra città
e la prima volta per me ea foggia e sono
sicuro che ritornano perché l'ospitalità
è stata talmente spettacolare che non si
può non ripetere e grazie veramente a te
di svolgere organizzatori che sono stati
anche quello straordinario
io mi chiamo matteo ceri sono un medico
sono un ricercatore sono neurofisiologo
sono associati tutto da nazionale fisica
nucleare o un lungo curriculum che non è
necessario qui declinare e sono qui per
raccontarvi un po un piccolo viaggio a
me piace fare divulgazione scientifica
ed è giusto che questa venga fatta
direttamente da chi poi magari accesso o
fai esperimenti che portano avanti alla
scienza
ora gli attori ma vedrete tra i titoli
piuttosto strani tre parole che magari
non necessariamente avete sempre insieme
sonno ibernazione animazione sospesa di
cosa stiamo parlando perché ne parliamo
allora io vorrei portarvi in un piccolo
viaggio che parte dal nostro cervello
origina dall'universo dal mondo che noi
pensiamo di percepire fuori ma che in
realtà fondamentalmente dentro di noi e
tutto quello che il nostro cervello
elabora e processa che rende la nostra
vita un'esperienza degna d'essere
vissuta tutti i nostri piaceri gioie
dolori sono tutti conservati qui dentro
e sono conservati qui dentro così tanto
che noi siamo abituati a vedere questo
tipo di immagini questo è una pet di un
cervello di una persona normale
qualunque che sta facendo la sua vita
mentre sveglio mentre attivo il cervello
è tutto colorato queste sono colori
artificiali ovviamente che noi diamo
dopo aver fatto questo tipo di esami ma
ci dà così anche psicologicamente la
misura di quanto il cervello si attiva
e purtroppo ci dà anche la misura di
quanto il cervello si spegnerà un giorno
che in effetti non sia più in grado di
compiere queste operazioni
quello che vedete non stara tenere dello
schermo è un cervello che non c'è più
allora questa questa strana dicotomia
vita morte noi inconsciamente abbiamo un
po sempre la percepiamo come uno stacco
netto cioè la vita c'è la morte ma in
realtà queste due condizioni sono molto
contante fra di loro di quanto non
possiamo pensare e non solo non è uno
stacco netto ma c'è tutta un'area grigia
fra 1 e l'auto
c'è tutta una condizione nella quale la
vita e la morte si avvicinano nelle
quali si può arrivare fino quasi a
toccare la morte pur mantenendosi la
possibilità di ritornare indietro non
parliamo di comi o di situazioni
patologiche parliamo di cose naturali e
quindi riportavano un piccolo viaggio
tra la vita e la morte diciamo così che
vedrà alcune condizioni in cui c'è un
suo cervello si trova in uno stato
diverso
il sonno rem sarà la prima tappa del
nostro del nostro viaggio seguito dal
sonno non rem seguito ulteriormente da
una condizione ancora più particolare
che l'ibernazione e per arrivare fino
quasi a toccare l'estremo limite
nell'animazione sospesa quindi iniziamo
questo particolare attività chiedendoci
prima di tutto ma perché dopotutto il
cervello si deve spegnere io questa
domanda non ho una risposta
non so dirvi perché e ci sono aspetti
evoluzionistici che potremmo anche
declinare per capirlo ma vi faccio
vedere un caso un caso un po particolare
che a me ha colpito pubblicato su lancet
qualche anno fa nel caso di un soggetto
di un paziente spagnolo che conduceva
una vita normale come tutti voi un
impiegato due figli una moglie un lavoro
normale nessuna particolare così
scintilla nella sua vita se non un
continuo mal di testa che lo
perseguitava da tanto tempo e assomiglia
a un certo punto un po stanco di diarrea
insomma c'è sempre quasi sempre qua
andiamo a farti una tac sorpresa
sorpresa
l'attacco mostra un cervello che non c'è
praticamente non c'è tutto questo nero
che vedete dietro di me alla mia destra
e lealtà liquido cerebrospinale sono
delle cavità che ci sono nel cervello
sono piene di liquido alla mia sinistra
vede come dovrebbe essere un cervello
normale questa persona però non era
esisteva maniera incosciente non avere
nessuna particolare problematica forse
con cui leggermente sotto la norma
ma andiamo chi di noi non conosce
qualcuno con cui un po sotto la norma
questo per dirvi che alla fine molti
sono ancora i misteri del cervello e di
come il cervello ci fa esistere per cui
iniziamo a vedere allora uno degli stati
più strani della nostra vita nel quale
entriamo e usciamo più volte tutti i
giorni il sonno rem
se non è ma è una condizione nella quale
il nostro cervello non è cosciente
perlomeno noi non siamo coscienti di
essere cosciente
probabilmente la sede l'attività onirica
molti sogni sono i vivi di quei sogni
colorati quei suoni che ci fanno pensare
veramente al sogno vengono probabilmente
fatti qui ma se ci pensate bene voi nei
vostri sogni
non sapete che state sognando non siete
artifici del vostro destino durante i
vostri sogni è uno stato un po diverso
un po particolare ma non solo per questo
qui vi faccio vedere solo per velocità
l'attività elettrica del cervello
durante il sonno rem che è praticamente
uguale molto simile molto simile a
quella che abbiamo quando siamo svegli
ma molte altre caratteristiche sono
curiosissima per esempio il tono
muscolare scompare siamo paralizzati
questa una giraffa come tutti i
mammiferi passano rem non è una
caratteristica umana e non certo gli
istituti mammiferi e come tutti i
mammiferi diventa paralizzata in questo
momento una paralisi flaccida cioè i
muscoli non si muovono più infatti il
collo tuc scende per terra molto curioso
poi si sveglia tutto normale e poi altre
cose curiose questa è una una
termografia un'immagine presa da una
telecamera particolare che misura le
temperature sulle superfici un po come
faceva predetto in un vecchio fini e
all'inizio del sonno rem alla mia
sinistra sia io che questo atto da
laboratorio la vostra testa alla vostra
sinistra né a destra sono tutti rossi
cosa vuol dire che ricchi di sangue il
sangue sulla nostra cute fruisce ed è
ricco di temperatura alla fine del sonno
rank sul sangue non c'è più se n'è
andato è stato tutto attratto
all'interno del corpo non sappiamo
perché mi spiego la tecnologia sta
studiando tutti effetti particolari che
però vengono guidati dal nostro cervello
così come le incapacità di rispondere al
freddo
se qualcuno di voi ha mai dormito al
freddo che non è piacevole quando entra
il sonno rem che sede questa cosa
scompare il nostro corpo non se ne non
se ne rende più conto quando si sveglia
poi in realtà inizia a controbattono
bene cosa succede nel sonno rem come il
nostro cervello nel sonno rem
questo è un cervello in una condizione
di veglia perché ovviamente per capire
cosa succede nel suono vogliamo prima
vedere un po come siamo svegli quando
siamo svegli e stimoliamo il cervello
stimoliamo un'area del cervello in
qualche modo questa informazione
riverbera nel cervello fa un eco
per alcune centinaia di mille secondi va
avanti e indietro e alterare del
cervello sanno cosa sta succedendo il
cervello iperconnesso e molto connesso
abbiamo parlato di connettività tutta
questa questa pomeriggio
vediamo nessuno degli organi più
connessi una delle strutture più
connesso dell'universo bene questa
connettività cambia durante il sonno rem
assomiglia a quella che c'è durante la
veglia
ma è un po minore non tutte le aree sono
interessate queste informazioni veneto
c'è stata un pò meno con un po di
ritardo con un po di difficoltà se
volete mettere in questo senso forse
questa è una delle cause all'origine
della bizzarria del contenuto onirico i
sogni sono sempre ricchi di particolari
dati da una strana bizzarria cosa ci
dice invece l'altra fase del sonno sono
rem cosa completamente diversa fatto da
un'attività elettrica molto ampia molto
riposante e il viado sonno ristorativo
avere il vero solo nel quale noi forse
ci riposiamo anche il nostro cervello
forse si riposa un po cosa succede se
stimoliamo lo so cervello nel sonno remo
succede che quell'informazione non
viaggia più resta lì dove è stata messa
questi sono esperimenti fatti da un
collega molto valido di milano che siamo
al cielo massimino allievo di giulio
tononi e in questo caso l'informazione
non è più trasmessa il cervello è del
connesso e noi entriamo e usciamo da
questa connessione de connessione tante
volte tutti i giorni
tante volte tutte le notti e tutte le
volte che giochiamo è una cosa che
riguarda anche il modo in cui noi
viviamo la velocità della nostra vita
quanto ci può dire questa fase del sonno
riguardo al modo in cui noi affrontiamo
gli anni che ci vengono davanti se
confrontiamo diverse specie fra di loro
per esempio in questo caso uomini gatti
adatti potrebbe essere il bel titolo di
un libro
scopriamo che in realtà la quantità di
sonno rem che facciamo e dei cicli di
sonno che facciamo o meno uguale nel
corso della giornata
cambia il numero rivolge che lo facciamo
una domanda resta quella
e questo numero di volte è più grande o
aumenta sempre di più più e piccolo non
rimane che consideriamo è più corta e la
sua vita quindi più siamo grandi più
vivremo a lungo e più sono si compatta
in qualche modo qualcuno ha suggerito
una fase del sonno potrebbe essere unita
universale di misura del tempo biologico
che confronti piccoli animali e grandi
animali in quanto siamo un po tutti
diversi in questo senso
ma torniamo al nostro viaggio cosa ci
può dire
una scienza dell'ibernazione cos'è
l'ibernazione questa una parola in cui
magari avete un po meno familiarità
qualcuno di voi la confonderà
sicuramente con ogni tanto compare sui
giornali e ricco magnate russo si fa
ibernare per tornare in vita fra mille
anni questo in realtà è un processo
diverso si chiama crioconservazione olio
e congelarsi fisicamente essere proprio
in un blocco di azoto liquido fondo
mentre l'ibernazione invece di cui
parliamo noi è quella che gli scoiattoli
e gli orsi i criceti fanno normalmente
che si chiama letargo un po così in
gergalmente gli sono arrivate diverse
forme di letargo il torpore è l'unità
elementare delle targhe un piccolo
letargo poi c'è l'ibernazione in climi
freddi che avviene per lungo tempo le
steve azione che a venire alta in
chimica li madagascar esempi sono
animali che fanno questo e ci sono
animali come lo scoiattolo artico che
riescano ad arrivare addirittura sotto
zero come temperatura corporea meno uno
meno due al mammifero che raggiunge la
temperatura più bassa nel mondo
che cos'è veramente letargo
l'ibernazione qui c'è un grafico c'è una
marmotta delle alpi e vantare un animale
molto carino ma
di fianco c'è un grafico e non
spaventatevi a volte il pubblico
generale il giornalista vede un grafico
di ceo di via matematica scuola è un
disastro mio maestro di bacchettava non
fatemi vedere queste cose ma è molto
semplice sono delle linee tracciate nel
tempo e vi spiego cosa guardare perché è
interessante questa curva e la curva
della temperatura del corpo di questa
marmotta qui e circa 37 gradi si legge
su questo a questa parte
vedete qui e 10 gradi questa è la
temperatura ambientale 8 gradi
questo è un periodo di torpore il
torpore che non è quello non è questo
freddo non è il raffreddamento della
temperatura corporea ma è quello che
succede in questa area grigia che vedete
improvvisamente qui va quasi a zero
questo è il metabolismo di questo
animale è la spesa energetica al consumo
d'ossigeno che questo animale mette in
pratica
il letargo e alla capacità che questi
animali hanno di fermare il loro consumo
di ossigeno e quindi di conseguenza di
raffreddarsi qua un esempio di
termografia potete vedere un animale
sopra che va in torpore e scompare
mentre quello sotto che in un ambiente
dove sta giocando non ha voglia di
andare in torpore resta sveglia dove
viene l'ibernazione perché ce l'abbiamo
sul pianeta compare 200 milioni di anni
fa quando gli eno zauri erano ancora
sulla terra e quando i mammiferi
compaiono sulla terra si trovano a dover
convivere con queste grosse bestie e per
vivere fanno quello che sono capaci
il nostro grande dono e proprio avere un
metabolismo più grande e più elevato
otto volte superiore a quello dei
rettili quindi poter vivere anche di
notte senza che il sole ci debba
scaldare per funzionare e di notti
dinosauri sono un po meno attivi perché
sono rettile quindi sopravviviamo
sopravviviamo per centinaia di milioni
di upper 100 milioni di anni così fino a
quando fortunatamente dinosauri si
estinguono sappiamo tutti come si sono
distinti dinosauri è stata un'ecatombe
un disastro su scala planetaria e una
volta che dinosauri si sono estinti i
mammiferi sono stati in grado di
ritornare alla vita diurna riprodursi
occupare tutte le nicchie ecologiche e
qualcuno di questi ha conservato la
capacità di andare in torpore
se vediamo quali sono i mammiferi che
vanno in tour pure in tutti gli ordini
di mammiferi il troviamo dispera siamo
anche di leopardo per un buonista questo
significa che i geni che sono necessarie
sopravvivere questa condizione erano
comuni al nostro antico predecessore a
quel mammifero che aveva iniziato vi
prego di nosari e che quindi
potenzialmente sono presenti in tutti i
mammiferi noi compresi arriviamo al
punto estremo
vediamo quanto possiamo arrivare vicini
ma l'ultima frontiera animazione sospesa
realtà non è molto diversa da quello che
vi ho raccontato adesso è una condizione
di letargo che viene indotta
artificialmente in un animale che non è
in grado di farlo
intanto pensiamo subito alla
fantascienza quando pensano questo
termine qui sono quattro fotogrammi di
quattro famosi film potete mettere alla
prova le vostre competenze per cercare
indovinarli se non vi svelerà il mistero
più tardi
io fortunatamente faccio parte di un
gruppo di ricerca dell'agenzia spaziale
europea il cui scopo è proprio quello di
cercare di sviluppare una procedura per
indurre letargo in e gli astronauti che
esploderanno sistema solare e non solo
per quelle realtà vedremo ovviamente si
parla di esplorazione spaziale e
d'ibernazione i giornali emilia di
solito ne ricavano articoli a volte
belli a volte magari un po più
sensazionalistici però tutto sommato
ritengo che faccia specie come si induce
animazione sospesa in un animale che non
va in letargo e c'erano stati diversi
tentativi negli ultimi dieci anni sono
stato fortunato devo dire ha avuto
un'idea un po diversa e ho capito che
c'era un piccolo gruppo di neuroni
quest'anno le costruzioni
tridimensionale di un cervello c'era un
piccolo gruppo di neuroni che funzionava
da interruttore è un interruttore
metabolico quando è acceso come cosa che
per noi è più o meno sempre il nostro
metabolismo bula a livelli dei mammiferi
altissimo ma quando si spegne in realtà
dovremmo entrare di letargo e questo
gruppo di neuroni e controllato da una
complessa rete di altri zone cerebrali
che adesso stiamo studiando questo
incontrato al cervello è veramente
iperconnesso e questa rete controlla
questo interruttore la mia idea era
stata quella di spegnere artificialmente
con un farmaco questo gruppo di neuroni
e quello che succede esattamente questo
vedete da un lato murato di laboratorio
e un animale che non va mai in letargo
in torpore che improvvisamente viene
trattato con questo farmaco e scompare
vedete la termografia non ce la fa più
vedere
dopo il giorno dopo essere tornato
normale dove è andato quando era
scomparso ancora lì con sé come voi
adesso lo vede che ha disegnato ma il
suo metabolismo era così basso la sua
temperatura così bassa che era quasi
indistinguibile dall'ambiente esterno
non era molto però era vivo e tornato
vivo ma era arrivato forse confine più
vicino a questo estremo limite che si
possa pensare
ora sono tante altre le applicazioni
cliniche che poi hanno scoperto possono
derivare da questo tipo di procedimento
per esempio il cervello inizia a fare
delle cose straordinarie i neuroni si
scommettono fra di loro nuovi marchio di
funzionamento paio nei neuroni e
potenzialmente sia una finestra d'azione
di intervento in cui si possono fare
cose
che non possiamo fare quando siamo
normali e tutte queste ora hanno dato
origine a nuovi filoni di ricerca
l'ultimo dei quali è ovviamente lo
spazio perché dovremmo parlare di
ibernazione per l'esplorazione spaziale
andare su marte a un lungo viaggio nove
mesi circa nelle migliori condizioni
otto mesi e mezzo su una cabina
telefonica volante con sei persone a
bordo sei persone e una vera da mangiare
per nove mesi l'andata nove mesi al
ritorno un po di tempo tra stare su
marte tutto questo costa un sacco di
soldi perché spedire delle cose in
orbita costa tantissimo dai 10mila ai
60.000 dollari al chilo a seconda di
quanto considerate come spesa sempre ci
sono altri problemi
se siete mai andati in barca con i
vostri amici di scuola siete tornati in
meno perché qualcuno è stato pugnalato
nella notte perché non lo potevate più
sopportare è difficile vivere senza
privacy per tanto tempo le stesse
persone e nelle simulazioni a terra due
persone su cinque sviluppano quella che
si chiama cabin fever sia un ottimo
attacco psicotico per cui attaccano
fisicamente le persone che sono con lui
non la riconoscono più come amiche
fantascienza pura
poi c'è un altro grosso problema forse
il problema al momento i raggi cosmici
radiazioni che per l'uomo sono piuttosto
pericolose e calcolando la quantità che
se ne assorbirebbe per andare su marte
sarebbe quasi tre volte quelle che ci
sono state di rossi ma il vantaggio che
se potessimo ibernare l'equipaggio non
abbiamo più bisogno di cibo perché lohan
trivellazioni non si mangia e non si
producono neanche scarti non si è
coscienti per cui non c'è nessun attacco
psicotico e bonus fra i bonus
abbiamo scoperto che in realtà le
cellule in ibernazione sono estremamente
resistenti alle radiazioni e quindi
ridurrebbero notevolmente il danno
provvisto di queste cose questo
ovviamente vale per un viaggio su marte
che tutto sommato è vicino ma anche per
quella che sarà la destinazione
successiva europa che già inizia a
serpeggiare in alcune alcuni corridori e
questo per farvi vedere che il cervello
può esistere in tanti modi
contemporaneamente e potremmo chiamarlo
il cervello di schrodinger i cervelli di
schrodinger parafrasando un pochino
impropriamente quello che aveva detto
del suo gatto e tutto questo per andare
poi un giorno a vedere questo cielo che
vediamo dietro di me e per vedere quanto
costa andare a vedere questo cielo che
il trattamento
questo puntino rosso mi interessa dirlo
è il costo del progetto genoma umano una
piccola puntino rosso
questo è il costo del progetto dello
human brain project progetto della
comunità europea dalla commissione
europea che cerca di simulare costruire
un cervello in silico questo il costo
delle lhc al cern bosone di higgs tutto
quello che ne consegue
questo l'incasso di avatar in un anno
questo è il costo e consumo di alcolici
negli stati uniti annuale e questo è il
costo dello sviluppo dei caccia f 35
questo per dirvi che la scienza realtà è
vero che costa molto ma costa molto
relativamente a cosa è davvero i governi
non possono permettersi più investimenti
in ricerca in educazione che
fondamentalmente l'unica cosa che ci ha
portato qua e che ci potrà portare
avanti così avanti che questo cielo che
vedi detto di me
in realtà io mi auguro che qualcuno di
voi magari possa vederlo perché non è un
cielo terrestre cielo marziano e quel
puntino in fondo che forse riuscito a
distinguere la terra con di fianco
la luna vi ho detto questo non posso che
salutarvi e ringraziarvi davvero per
l'attenzione
nella video tramite dedicato grazie
ancora
[Applauso]